abba
je prends je prends pour moi merci
voilà c'est fini fin de fin de séance
fin de festival
il est temps de de ce comté se
reconnaître qui d'entre nous qui il
entre nous a été touché par l'érotisme
sulfureux d'abdellatif kechiche qui a
été ému par les sans-grades d'hollywood
car un maintien je me trompe déjà dès le
début sur une première voyelles le
camping tarantino les revenants
sénégalais de mati diop qui a été
bouleversé par le journal intime et
sentimentales de pedro almodovar qui a
pris de plein fouet le choc ladj ly
comme moi céline sciamma l'epra dardenne
combien de divisions
partout dans les cafés dans les bars les
soirées les plages sous les pavés sous
les plages les colères des angolais des
discussions j'ai aimé j'ai adoré j'ai
tellement aimé que j'ai envie de le voir
le film
j'ai détesté mais je ne suis pas sûr de
l'avoir vu je tu n'as pas été au cinéma
don cherry en août à cannes je pas le
temps quand même il est génial ce film
je crois je crois que je vais aller le
voir et cetera pas s'engueuler se battre
discuter serait conçue autour d'un film
quel luxe incroyable dans cette époque
pendant que pierre lescure se tient le
menton ce qu'il signe que tout va bien
dès le début et puis un moment
tous ces films reine d'un jour resteront
derrière nous comme ça comme des enfants
laissés à la consigne d'une gare oublié
et puis très vite la nostalgie tout de
suite après le temps présent voilà
la musique me soutient ma vie est
sublime je dis un mot la musique par
radio polémique
coup de coeur sans opinion adieu veaux
vaches cochons à dieu
talant noeud papillon
adieu à l'écumé des choses
le resteront avec une petite marque
indélébile en nous une émotion une
émotions procurées par un film par un
plan par un mouvement un je ne sais quoi
et sur little je ne sais quoi c'est ça
qu'on cherche dans l'émotion émotions
sinon selon l'avis siens pas d'émotions
bienvenue à la cérémonie de clôture du
72e festival international du film de
cannes
[Applaudissements]